les républicains la parole est à
monsieur yves albarello mu mais merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
tous les français sans exception ont été
traumatisés par les attentats perpétrés
sur notre sol le 13 novembre dernier
après c'est dramatique attentat
la riposte a été immédiate et couronné
de succès je tiens ici même à féliciter
le courage et l'efficacité de nos forces
de l'ordre et des services de secours
bien sûr mes chers amis nous regrettons
le temps perdu
mais aujourd'hui la réponse ne peut plus
attendre
il vous faut maintenant agir j'ai moi
même signaler à votre ministre de
l'intérieur en juillet dernier le cas
d'un jeune français dont le comportement
inquiète et son entourage tant sa
radicalisation et est devenue évidente
le maillon faible
ce sont les mosquées salafistes
radicaliser à lagny sur marne commune de
ma circonscription
nous nous doutions que la mosquée
pouvait abriter des imams radicaux
lors de la perquisition du 2 décembre un
pistolet a été retrouvé ainsi que des
munitions de calibre 7,62 pourra me de
guerre de type kalachnikov des chants
religieux à la gloire des martyrs du
djihad une école coranique clandestine
des vidéos de propagande de l'état
islamique
ces mosquées radicaliser implantés sur
tout le territoire national
au nombre de 89 selon le ministère de
l'intérieur se distingue des modes des
mosquées traditionnelles par leurs
pratiques en rendant certains jeunes
plus vulnérables à la radicalisation
cela constitue un véritable danger pour
la sécurité des français
ces imams venus d'ailleurs influent
leurs thèses radia infuse pardon leurs
thèses radicales qui plaisent aux jeunes
ces lieux de culte qui noyautent
représentent de véritables viviers pour
ne pas dire de couveuse pour les futurs
combattants au jihad
monsieur le premier ministre quelles
sont les mesures que vous comptez mettre
en oeuvre pour fermer définitivement ses
mosquées radicaliser guimond à mentalist
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur manuel valls
ce président monsieur le député
albarello île intérieure aurait pu bien
sûr vous répondez y l'état londres cet
après midi dans le cadre d'une rencontre
avec d'autres ministres de l'intérieur
pour rejoindre là encore tous les
efforts pour lutter contre le terrorisme
contre l'état islamique qui s'attaquent
non seulement à la france mais qui a
plusieurs cibles vous le savez en europe
et dans le monde
un certain nombre d'éléments ont conduit
nous ont conduit à réaliser le 2
décembre dernier vous l'évoquez la
perquisition de la mosquée de lagny sur
marne ainsi que dix perquisitions
administrative individuelles visant des
personnes participant directement à sa
gestion ou à son organisation
cette mosquée qui était déjà je me
permettez cette expression dans le
collimateur de nos services puisque une
procédure de fermeture avaient déjà été
engagés devant passer en conseil des
ministres a été fermée en vertu de la
loi du 3 avril 1955
ces opérations ont permis de découvrir
une structure scolaire totalement
dissimulé parfaitement illégal l'état
étaient donc fondées invoqué cette
disposition de la loi sur l'état
d'urgence
mais au-delà de ce seul motif des
éléments établissements clairement que
cette mosquée était un élément
structurant d'une filière de recrutement
djihadiste était à l'origine d'une
filière où on trouve un certain nombre
de personnes dont un prêcheur de la
haine faisant l'apologie du djihad et de
la mort en martyr et qui a joué un rôle
majeur dans l'endoctrinement de
personnes qui se sont par la suite
portés volontaires pour le jihad en
syrie aussi bien pour le compte de
l'état islamique que du jamaat al nassr
à cette personne avait également fait
déjà l'objet d'un gel administratif de
ses avoirs en qualité de gestionnaire de
la mosquée de nombreux éléments
démontrent que cette filière était
pérenniser donc que cela soit pour la
mosquée de la nuit ou pour d'autres
mosquées avec les éléments de l'état de
droit avec les éléments de l'état
d'urgence
nous allons poursuivre ces perquisitions
nous allons poursuivre cette traque de
cet islamisme radical de ce salafisme
qui corrompt une partie de notre
jeunesse et nous devons être
intraitables agir les perquisitions du 2
décembre dans cette mosquée ont permis
vous l'évoquez aussi de saisir des
documents relatives au jihad
un disque dur dissimulé plusieurs
ordinateurs ainsi qu'une arme et des
munitions qui justifie des poursuites
judiciaires
c'est vrai à la nuit ça peut être le cas
aussi dans d'autres mosquées dans lieux
d'autres lieux de culte même si nous
savons que les éléments de
radicalisation se font aussi sur
internet ou en prison
en concluant je veux dire monsieur le
député est rappelé que les musulmans de
france sont les premières victimes de
l'islamisme radical
un certain nombre d'établissements de
mosquées sont noyautées ou déstabilisé
par des éléments qui cherchent en
prendre le contrôle
et s'il n'est pas du ressort de l'état
d'organiser la religion en revanche il
est de son devoir de veiller à éviter
ces déstabilisations et agir
efficacement soit par la voie
administrative soit par la voie
judiciaire
chaque fois que c'est nécessaire oui
notre adversaire notre ennemi c'est
l'islamisme radical et il doit savoir
que l'état fort de soutien de la
représentation parlementaire sera
intransigeant et déterminée et en même
temps je veux ici encore une nouvelle
fois affirmé un message de soutien à nos
compatriotes musulmans
l'état se doit agir contre l'islamisme
radical
mais l'état a aussi un devoir de
protection vis-à-vis de nos compatriotes
et de nos concitoyens musulmans pour
éviter les amalgames qu'on entend de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique mais qu'on
entend aussi dans notre pays c'est ça la
république et je voulais le dire en ce
jour d'anniversaire de la loi de 1905
merci monsieur le premier ministre pour
le groupe socialiste républicain et
citoyen